i want to get a beef with her and i'm
kidding here's the thing about the cool
her daddy thing
sure god bless her right i would say i
don't know her
god bless her yeah six
60 million dollars they're not gonna
make that money back
absolutely not nowhere they won't make
six million
let's be honest which barstool
still owns yes is what drives the whole
thing i think
right people buy the merch that's the
most profitable thing i would win
i think the closest i would get to the
call her daddy podcast would be a hat
that says call her daddy i'd wear that
you'd do that
yeah but i'm not gonna i tried to listen
to an episode
what is it because i've never listened
but she's getting
60 million i made four seconds in
and i turned it on i said no was it that
bad yeah it's just it's not but it's not
for me though
right you know what i mean you got to
know what is for you interesting like to
me it's like
if it was just like is it an exploration
of like anal
where you listen to it and you go how do
you take a big one without getting an
anal fissure
like is it because they better fix those
titles man right because i'm not having
it
all right yeah i didn't i i i'm
i think if the podcast money now is
getting silly yeah
this is uh this is silly this is bitcoin
that's right from like
uh five six years ago it's getting silly
yeah
and i think people are i think these
companies are gonna just eventually go
oh we learned our lives oh they're gonna
pull back
hard they're pulling back spotify likes
rogan
right um i don't know if they're in love
with it they
like it's a solid like what's good
people are coming to the platform
i've heard they don't like the ringer
the bill simmons
thing they're not thrilled is that like
a sports thing yeah it's a sports thing
and they gave him 100 million
yeah they're just they're just they're
just giving
people pretend are they they're just are
they
is the money even real or is they
spotifying the money is just spotting
the money
[Laughter]
it's on loan yeah because i feel like
i'm gonna start a podcast i'm gonna come
in way too late
yeah i get a book of coupons yeah i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get an iou
from spotify i don't it's weird
it's too much money yeah people are
getting it
i don't know yours is already on there
so what is the thing is
yeah do you just be like do you walk in
there with like a black trench coat and
a suitcase and yeah i fill it with money
or i take it off spotify no they're not
going to give us
anything what is what is what is spotify
save what is their communication
with us it's been like uh you can be
honest we're not getting any money
there's been no offer but our agent lot
like he lies and says he's getting us
money yeah he says a deal might come
through
they make stuff up yeah of course and
they tell you that there's a big deal
coming
and they're it's just not true yeah
siriusxm
yeah serious and all the we're getting
yeah and they'll call you up there like
there's a company called
clincher like it's all a fake like thing
like it's
digital media content create and they're
really interested
it's just a general name with the
company yeah bill's serious cult
he wants to give you 250 million dollars
he's like no youtube at 300 million
dollars
now you'll never see it because it's not
real but tell me how you feel
did you like the number yeah i think
they offered rogan money and he said no
and then like when the pandemic hit
they're like how about this and he's
like okay let's do it
but does that mean you take your podcast
off other
platforms what does that mean it did for
him right joe you can't get anywhere but
spotify oh
spotify exclusive right for your daddy i
also believe
exclusively call your dad all her daddy
let's call her dad but call your daddy
so much funnier
daddy is better if it was a show where
she had to call her father
and tell him all the things she did
sexually
i would really prefer that show i'm
gonna tell you now i'm listening
now i'm in like she calls him up and
she's like dad
like it's the fourth episode he's like
oh my god he's like
like he knows everything every art it
starts with the ringing
and then it's just him picking up that
click in and it goes
now what he's so dejected yeah
and she's just like well you know it's
another episode of call your daddy
hi daddy and he's like hey and she goes
all right so i want to tell you the
story when i was in cancun
he's like you just hear him like here's
your eyes clinking in his glass
he's like jesus [ __ ] cries episode
you hear the phone go down and then a
gunshot
he just blows his brains out call your
daddy
but that that uh that one's exclusive
too i think when they give you the big
money
yes when they roll out the biggens you
can't
you they spotify's like they can't find
this show
right if they find this podcast
anywhere but spotify yeah we'll kill
them like that's
the level we'll kill your daddy yeah
kill your dad
so those are the big deals they made
they made the ringer they made rogan
they made call her daddy
mm-hmm uh jack shepherd's pocket what
did dak shepard get
i i read 60 but you never remember the
whole thing positivity isn't he just
isn't his biggest claim to fame being
married to kristen bell
i kind of believe it probably was but
now he's got this massive show and i
don't what is it
it's armchair expert what what what is
it so he's like a
he's like a therapist to to like paul
rudd and seth rogen and all these people
why i'm like curious
aren't they're really rich and famous so
what's the problem
yeah you don't need someone rich to tell
you that you're rich still
i'm aware of it right the arm chair is
nice yeah
that's all it is like i can tell this is
a good armchair thank you
what i don't know anything about his
podcast i'm sure he's a good guy i don't
want to find out a guy is pretending to
be an expert and getting paid 60 million
dollars
yeah because there's a there's an actual
expert very upset
yeah how about how many experts that are
actual experts have
zero dollars maybe i could get some of
them
so the the website says the armchair
expert podcast celebrates the messiness
of being human
i mean i keep these windows open yeah
let me just jump out from here canal
aurora is with us by the way
follow canal aurora give people your
social it's uh
all day kca all day kca is that
everywhere is that on
everything it's on it's on twitter it's
on q anon
it's on instagram instagram it's the
website it's everything
4chan yeah fundamentalist.com
i'm everywhere hilarious comedian
started
started with me um you know we were like
like i was going to say thugging it out
i don't know why we were not
[ __ ] yeah you said we were thugging
it out at open minds i'm thugging it out
yeah i don't know what thugging it out
means but
we were at open mics in 2010
yes late 2010 yes i met you
i was doing my first set ever
at which i might have done better than
tonight i'm kidding i love new york
uh it was i was at a coffee shop in
long island called wild child slash
tattoo parlor tattoo parlor yes
right you bomb and you'd hear the needle
buzz
you you hear whenever you bomb it's just
a guy going oh
yeah this guy and they were all going to
like get their
like they'd get like some chicks named
tattooed on them right that tattoo shop
did a lot of like
like uh like whatever what is the term
when you like turn one tattoo into
another one
a transformation maybe i don't know it
was a lot of names being changed
yes and dogs faces because i it was a
lot of dogs
but i remember there was always like a
consultation yeah like we would be like
we'd walk in and we'd see somebody and
they'd be like okay so here's what we
could do
and say you made a mistake here's what
we could do we could turn your
ex-girlfriend's name
into r.i.p and a nice 911.
you could do like an r.i.p right the
heroes right
towers and they're like okay i
constantly heard from those uh tattoo
chairs
you know this is permanent
now you know this is permanent right you
know you can't walk in here tomorrow
and get rid of this and by the way they
should like that was such a
weird eerie thing for us to hear doing
stand-up comedy because it's like oh
[ __ ] this is permanent
yeah for a lot of us it was permanent
and um i was doing my set and it was
like whatever dumb
i could all have like a little net book
yes i remember that yeah it was a little
like a net book
right and you were like typing on it and
every now and then i would say something
funny and he'd go
huh he'd have like a little like huh
yeah it was and then and then i was
because
i was a guy that wanted to like like
impress and then
there was another guy with a scott right
who ideally didn't
want to impress he gave me a fake
name yeah the first time i met him what
what did he
he's like my name is michael and i was
like this is i'm going to know this man
for the rest of my life
yeah i'm livid why why did he do that i
don't know he's just a weird you know
scott's a weird guy he's an odds he's a
great guy
i love him but he's nuts but i remember
that that was the beginning of and then
the canal like we would go into the city
and like
do stand-up comedy at these crazy places
yeah i started doing this thing called
trip sunday yes
and you would take two comics i would
take two comics with me
so it would be three comics three mics
uh one day basically 100 miles of
driving and it was usually me
you dennis yeah yeah it would be i would
alter it always switch around
yeah because sometimes you might be
booked sometimes sometimes you're like
you know what man i don't want to eat my
[ __ ] ass three days three
to three mikes in a row that was a great
day of comedy
yes because it was we did a a hipster
mic
yeah a black mic yeah and then uh long
island
club mic sad mind
it would it would always end good or bad
at a pizza shop across the street yes
eating eating a couple slices and one of
the saddest moments and i
want to let you tell the story because
you remember exactly how it happened
right was
the night you decided you had to move
into new york city so we're doing
it's like another trip sunday i mean
there's a hundred miles of driving for
one day
it's a lot yeah because we would start
in long island or i'd pick you up
yes or you'd come to my mom's place and
then we shoot into the city
yeah we do these mics we're finding
trying to figure out parking
trying to get to these things and then
uh then shoot out to long island and not
like regular not like
you know a simple like new hyde park
we're talking in there
deep deep huntington yes yeah so and
it's not every day would everything work
in fact most of the times it wouldn't
right you're just eating it all day long
so this day
nobody's happy yeah we're all we're in
the car we're
now in deep long island huntington we
had bombed at the hipster mike
yes bombed in the black room yes yes now
we're heading back home
right and we're now at this mic
in in huntington it's a second floor
it's this place it was called
chesterfields
yes yeah and it was like it had some
history to it but nobody knows what
nobody knows the history but everyone
always said you know this place is known
i think they used to say eddie murphy
started here if you started yeah
no one knew what that meant i think
eddie murphy took the bus that passed by
there i still have no idea what that
meant
no clue but people would be like have
some respect murphy started here yeah
but like you should they have a picture
and it's a white guy named eddie murphy
yeah
yeah by the way it's also these are the
most racist people in america
telling you that eddie murphy started
that right i'm like you're an
insanely racist person like you know
they're just taking pride in the
accomplishments of like there's a
picture of a
murphy but there's racial epidemics he's
scrawled
on the glass eddie murphy started here
he should have stayed here
okay so we're we're sitting there and uh
i'm sitting next to you and we're just
watching
people go up yeah and then a guy
gets up and he is a rodney dangerfield
impersonator yes
as to why you need to do rodney's
material at an open mic right beyond me
yeah
it's already tried yes yeah he did it on
letterman
right i mean you know what i mean he did
you know you're not working anything out
yeah you're right yeah it's like why do
you need to retry material on
carson does that get no respect for it
yes yeah this is for your audience it
does
for whatever birthday party has hired
you yeah
yeah this is gonna be fine who quality
controls rodney dandruff feels material
but the guy's up there he's got the suit
he's got the tie
yeah he's shaking the tie i got no
respect yeah
and then you hear somebody yell from off
stage
what the [ __ ]
and we look over because we're like this
is an open mic nobody should be heckling
right it's art it's mostly comics anyway
yeah and we look over and
by the door is another rodney
dangerfield impersonator
dressed in a suit and red tie
going you stole my act
in complete earnestness yes no to did
the extent to which this is not a joke
yeah that it was not that no one
appreciated this in any in a comedic way
at all
so what the [ __ ] was genuine yeah he was
shaken to his core he walked into a
rodney
he saw the other one and was like what
the [ __ ]
and he goes he yells from off stage just
cause i had a heart attack
you think you can do my act yes
[Laughter]
which is rodney's act whatever right
and and i lean over to you and i just
whisper
i'm moving next week i move to the city
so
first of all the rodney one riding gets
off
the next rodney yeah then like they let
him go up like
right after right right because he's
like upset
yeah and he does look sick like he's
not done he's older he's pale
he had legitimately suffered a heart
attack he was
like in recovery for a cardiac incident
he cuts the line and he goes this is how
you do it
and does more rodney material and then
he goes like this
he goes he goes i'm here and he goes
i'm recovering from a heart attack i
don't know if i can still do this yeah
and i just want to try this out because
that's the way i make money
yes and i want to know if i can still do
it she now it's like the added pressure
of like
not lj and he wasn't that good no
i could barely tell it was rodney i'm
gonna tell you right now
doing a rodney dangerously impersonation
yeah it's a young man's game
it's not it's yes and by a young man i
mean 40s yeah
yes yeah um and uh and then i was like i
gotta go and you were the first
um amongst us yes to have to leave
yeah i lived in an apartment in the east
village yes in alphabet city
alphabet city yeah cnn ninth and you
were the first one and
i was so impressed and everybody was
like [ __ ] he's doing it yeah he's
actually doing it right he's actually
leaving
he's not gonna have pizza with us
anymore no he's not
leaving and then uh and then you moved
right after i moved pretty soon yeah
yeah yeah
i moved pretty soon because i used to
hang out with you yes and i used to and
i'm like man
come on this is better right i just
realized it was better i'm like this
works
yeah this is what you we should have
been doing we were because it was easy
this is the thing this is the trap
it's easy to do open mics in long island
because you
drive to the thing yes you drive you
park your car
yes there's a parking lot yes and you
walk right in
right do your set and then you leave
right it's not like the city where
you're on the subway
yes you're someone is dancing in front
of you
yes and you're like i gotta make these
jokes work right and then you go mike to
mike to mike it's not like that
in long island you're still the same
person yeah but you're just doing comedy
yeah that's the problem not you could
still work at verizon
right and do your [ __ ] yes so it's
when you make that
sacrifice to move into new york city
you're taking on a different identity
i had a conversation with some comics
and they're like well what makes you a
comic
a comedian right and they're like is it
money is i'm like well i think that you
got to give up a certain amount
yes and that's what it is you're right
yeah and a lot of these guys moved from
other places
yeah here to do comments it it has to be
to me when i look at it i don't think
it's money yeah
to me it has to be the organizing
principle of your life
yes that's what i view it as right to be
a real comedian
yeah to be somebody who does comedy
whatever but if you're a comedian
to do it it's got to be the organizing
principle of your life meaning
i'm a comedian and these are the choices
i made
in pursuit of that you could make money
and it can still not be the organizing
principle of your life
absolutely there are people that we met
in long island we were just like
yeah this is what i get paid to do this
and you're like
who people pay for this we always knew
what we didn't want to be
yeah i think that's a great thing about
starting in long island right
listen i went back to long island and i
was at the diners there and i was you
know
showing my friends there and i'm like
i'm
really happy and listen i love long
island yeah i grew up there
but i'm really happy i'm i got out of
there
yeah man i'm really when you go back to
those diners
yeah they stink they're horrible yeah
they're terrible and you know what it is
there's like four good diners in the
entire long island i mean
i think they all used to be better but
now it's just but you also look at the
people
right and you look at everything and you
go you know what i'm glad my journey was
out
right i'm glad my journey was out of
here absolutely
you know yeah and it doesn't mean that
like
i won't eventually move back there and
get addicted to pills
i thought we went to a uh a dar williams
concert
yes okay yes so darwin is a
folk singer yeah and you put me on to
dar williams and she's not bad
she i i saw her youtube live yes
during the pandemic so many people right
now are like they hate when they
when there's actually incontrovertible
proof that i suck dick
yeah and yes they hate it they're like
because they can ignore it for
so much content and then every now and
then they're like
[ __ ] but not here not not here not when
dar is yeah
dar williams who's like a folk singer
who like he's like oh
she's um northeastern yeah
like uh lives in like you know the
hudson river valley yes
that's where we saw her yeah we saw her
purple crayon purple crayon
yeah she's uh you know she's always
trying to like spring terrorists from
jail i respect
him she was like banging the tambourine
outside like
you know some terrorist [ __ ] thing
yeah how was the youtube
it was good it was great it was fun it
was like you know we're in the pandemic
we were doing the pandemic i was like
what else am i going to do
i got a little upset with her because
the last time i saw her in brooklyn she
started bringing out like a bunch of
other people like
she put out a poet no i don't want that
yeah no no no she started bringing out
people and i started going
hey man do the hour right do the house
she just this is the pandemic so
nobody's visiting good i was like this
is perfect you gotta do the work yeah
like she'd bring out a poet
and then somebody did a poem and then
she like brought like someone from the
neighborhood up
yeah in brooklyn i don't care about your
gardening issues yeah
right yeah it was kind of like that
right it's kind of like and
somebody's talking about like voting for
like
it's voting for like a councilwoman i'm
like hey
and everything was like i'm just like at
least play guitar in the background
something
like some [ __ ] yeah doing that it's
like if i came on this podcast and
talked about a leaky fire hydrant
right like i gotta tell you guys what
really matters here
like i'll do it on my personal time
right make it the show
yeah don't make it the [ __ ] show
right
sheath underwear dot com it's the best
underwear and we support them
the owner of sheath underwear robert
what's his name
patron he's being charged right now for
war crimes of the hague
and we still support him and
we think that that woman that pregnant
woman did have a bomb
and i think that the evidence will show
that and i think robert acted
um appropriately sheath underwear is
great it's got a pouch for your junk
so you don't chafe very important in the
summer
great underwear can be used as a bathing
suit go to sheath underwear dot com
promo code tim you save 20
do you know how important it is uh not
only
right now because it's the summer and
sheath underwear is great underwear
but to support robert who is in the
fight of his life
right now being charged
uh with a war crime for an act
in iraq okay
where he shot a pregnant woman in her
stomach
i know for a fact that he did that
as a last resort
and i support
sheath underwear because i support
robert
and he didn't even she didn't even die
yeah from the shot in the stomach
this is what people don't realize she
lost the baby
that's sad they're accusing him they're
saying that after he shot her
a man matching his description doused
her with kerosene
and lit her on fire i don't believe that
that hasn't been proven if it was proven
that he did it i'm sure there's a really
damn good reason
that he lit that woman on fire
after shooting her baby sheath underwear
dot com
promo code tim to save 20 you know he
was dishonorably discharged
from the military and they're kind of
turning their back on him
because they're saying he kind of went
awol and uh it was like an apocalypse
now situation
where he's basically running his own
thing
and they said he was not taking orders
and he didn't respect the chain of
command
he was just kind of going out and
butchering women and children
what i think he was doing is what needed
to be done
to uh secure
uh his brothers and fight for our
nation's
interests support him
and not that lying [ __ ] that he lit on
fire
sheath underwear.com promo code tim
folks so many people right now are
struggling with mental illness
as a quarantine is ending people are
full of all kinds of anxieties and they
need to go back out into the world
they need to have the confidence and the
mental stability to go out there and
take advantage
of all the great opportunities coming in
the in the current uh gig
economy well we think better help is the
way to do it
it's an online counselor service they
provide many types of help that may not
be available
in physical locations depending on where
you live
log on right now and start speaking to a
counselor in under 48 hours they have
licensed professionals
you can change one at any time if you
don't vibe with them
but ah is better
better help is better it's better
i love help do you like help
i like getting hoped but what about if
it's the help is better
that sounds nice and that's my favorite
thing about
it log on log in
check in and then you're fine
you'll feel good and happy and warm and
friendly and free
you'll be able to dance under the stars
the children will look to you for wisdom
you'll become an elder in the community
with respect
you'll get the new big job in the corner
office
and you'll have a sailboat if you go on
better help
the girls and the guys will be happy
when you come into the local tavern
grinning ear to ear
because you've unloaded all the stuff
you had to say
to the person that better help
you'll walk into the luncheonette and
they'll say oh biff is here
they'll make you loose meat sandwich
they'll sit you down and pour you a cold
one
and all will be right with the world
because you went to better hell
you'll walk into the car dealership and
instead of seeing you as a mark
they just want to railroad steal from
they'll see he was a person that they
want to help
put you into a good car drive you around
something nice and shiny they'll buy you
soda pop and
tell you all the secrets and they'll
take care of you good carry because
you're a different man
because it better help at the beach club
they'll give you the
the good towels the ones that are hot
that just came out of the dryer
because of better help the ice cream
truck will no longer be out of the thing
you don't you want
they'll give it right to you and when
you try to pay
they'll say your money is no good here
and you'll fight with them a little bit
you'll say you need the money and
they'll go
you need the money and you'll go does it
look like i need the money
i have a [ __ ] lexus and they'll laugh
and they'll take the money from you and
say you're right you're a successful man
you know why because it better help
it's sponsored they're sponsoring our
podcast
10 off your first month of better help
go to betterhelp.com
betterhelp.comslashtimd
betterhlb.com timdy in all seriousness
it's a great way it's a truly great way
to talk to people to connect
to love to laugh to live
sometimes you gotta lose until you win
do you understand um yeah i think i
understand
yeah i had
to i had to lose you to love me
oh that's that song you always listen to
i don't think it's a song i think it's a
way of life
it's selena gomez that's right that's
who it is i don't always listen to it
but i listen to it
occasionally you listen to that and then
the taylor swift uh
summer one what is it uh it's called
cruel summer
cruel summer yeah podcast is sponsored
by a better help and tim dylan show
listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com betterhelp.comd
what have you like you were in new york
for the entire pandemic yes
and that and that's a lot of people left
yes
a lot of people people went home they
went back to their to their
you know the cities that they came from
comics and do you judge that
no okay no why am i it's like good
good yeah go home right you need this
mentally you need this yes they're
unwell
yeah they've been here too long yes it's
this is the same thing i'll get art like
you know this is what i said about when
you start here right
when you start here what really sucks is
that when you start
in i don't know chicago and you come to
new york
you come to new york and then you get
you you sharpen your teeth you go back
to chicago you murder
right your self-esteem chips are filled
right and now it's like oh i feel
ready to go back into that muck that's
the city yes when you start in new york
city there's no place to collect
self-esteem
no so a lot of these people are long
overdue for for a little hit
they're a little hit they're a little
hit of self-esteem yeah they need it
back
a a home-cooked meal yes something
someone to hug them
i think it was good for a lot of people
to go and reconnect
yes with family right and maybe
they needed to reconnect with um
who who they were before they moved to
places like new york
or their original psychiatrist yes yeah
or the original
yeah absolutely it knows how to help
right exactly like
you were long overdue for these
anti-depressants yeah
it's it's [ __ ] it's
wild to think about who we all were
like before we knew that this
could happen right and then
now having this [ __ ] think about
death in a real way yeah absolutely
in an actual real way like like yeah
this ends and we don't know when
right could be sooner is it not like you
know
i remember like you know like
comorbidities
when that start you know which is you
know you know fat
you know i just remember like when they
started talking about comorbidities
right morbidities
i was like you know i just get nervous
i'm like what is what are these
comorbidities
and and and i don't have diabetes or
anything like that but they're like
that's a big one i'm like yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a big there's a comic
on the bigger side
who was he he died yeah yeah this guy
kenny ortega big guy
funny dude funny guy could kill in
pretty much any room
and unfortunately passed away got
coveted passed away and that's the thing
like you start thinking about him like
[ __ ] i'm like all right i don't have
diabetes
right i'm like but i [ __ ] smoke i
don't i'm not smoking now but i'm like
and then you have the weight right and
then i'm 36.
right i'm like i'm not and they're like
you know i'd always look at that chart
was like well when the brackets of your
head the brackets i'm like
well people in their 30s but i'm like
i'm 36.
yeah and it it's you know and and i was
an alcoholic
and a drug addict right for a decade
over a day well over decades yeah
from 13 to 25 what about 12 years
and you go you go yeah i don't know that
i want to go to the dance
no with this stay home yeah yeah and a
lot of
people went home they went back to their
family and i don't judge them for it go
for it right
do that and also it's your family you
don't even know if they're gonna live
right you don't know if your parents are
gonna live yeah so you're gonna sit
there and
what tough it out in new york city right
that's
insane behavior i know a lot of people
that went
back home to me for me there's no home
to go that's
and there hasn't been a home to go
forever right right yeah and um
i guess i could have went home right but
i mean i live with my girlfriend
right no yeah you're the life yeah i
have a certain age
yeah yeah yeah where it's harder to do
that right and it's harder to do that my
father and his wife would have been like
please
die alone like they would have been like
please like die
like have the decency right after all
the [ __ ] you've talked about us
after all the the money you've made like
dragging our names through the mud
please do not come back here to die like
i mean
did i want to die there like do i want
to die there with my stepmother rolling
her eyes
rolling her eyes out nobody wants to be
dying and having somebody give you a
shady look yeah nobody wants like a
dirty look like right like not so funny
now or you're fat ass and i'm just like
my last few actions would be to cough on
you
[Laughter]
yeah i mean so there was nowhere but
then you start thinking about like i'm
like if i
die these were dark thoughts like you
have a girlfriend yeah i'm single
i mean i guess i could call one of these
guys in their early 20s and i've
you know [ __ ] because they like hotel
rooms and sneakers and going
hey would you want to sit by my bedside
while i die
i don't know i'm like hey no they'll
straight up be like am i in a will or
something
i'll have to like i'm like yeah yeah
yeah but it's [ __ ] right
because i've been i you don't have much
i have this career
right i have the career yes that's what
i have and the career is good
but the career is the least the last
thing you want
yes if you're dying right right right
but if when there's no opportunities
it's the career is the first thing you
want so
the career is what you want it's either
first or last in a lot of places
yeah yeah it's weird to think about
because i had those thoughts you know i
had those thoughts like i was on the
roads i was on the road
during the pandemic when cases would
drop well they were traveling last
summer or people like it's over and i'm
like all right
you get a few shows in and then we're
like it ain't over and yeah
cases went up and then we back off the
road but like i was out on the road i
got
my opener was like 24 25 and he's fine
he was young yeah and he's like his
whole thing was he's like
no no one's [ __ ] anymore and i can't
go out to bars
and my old thing in my head i'm like i'm
gonna die alone yeah
you know what i mean yeah like i'm like
well i understand that he's like yeah
the [ __ ] bars
these chicks on tinder they're weird
because the pandemic i'm like
understood right but also i will
gonna die here alone but
but in his to his uh to what he's saying
yeah you know not being able to go out
to the bars and these restaurants
closing
yeah some of them had to go yes yes some
of these restaurants had yeah
it was i and it's just like a friend
said that like oh they can use
covet as an excuse right to close up yes
but some of them good
yeah i'm happy your dream was crushed
some of them need to go i didn't need to
eat at your shitty burger
restaurant yeah that people showed up to
it had horrible brunch
yes and it's like people were like oh
this is no good
board up the walls yeah i'm happy good
yeah you know what
i i hope somebody i don't want to say
death but
i just hope someone was affected because
i don't want it coming back yeah
yeah no i want a little lung scar i
don't want someone
sponsoring this place i don't want to go
fund me appearing no i don't want it
i don't i hope you realize your life
shouldn't be dedicated to sriracha aioli
no get out of my life yeah no so there
are necessary changes yeah you're
jarring things yeah
no you're jarring you annoy me
do you think differently now about
anything uh i mean right now
this is the thing you said something i
heard you on on some on uh you were
saying that new york city
is is frightening to some capacity
uh when you were here briefly probably
it was there was
i was it was it was we were in times
square late at night that's that's what
i want to do
i wanted to bring that up yes because a
lot of you know you said that a lot
about and you know people think
times square is just all of new york
city right
but you're right times square at first
when i heard you say that i was like
man tim he's going a little too much and
i know and then
i went to times square yeah and i was
like oh this place is
haunting yeah no it's this one it's just
a little weird yeah
i mean it is you listen it's still the
greatest city in the world sure
but i i always got to be honest i mean
i've never been to tokyo
who knows sure well it it
threw me a little bit yes because i said
this is
you know it's odd scary yeah it was
scary you could hear
here's the thing i think i'm gonna get
raped yeah it's not good
right yeah when someone may rape me as a
goof
[Laughter]
not even it's not even sexual at that
point it's just something to do
you could hear a syringe fall yes
and it's and that's when it's terrifying
that's when it's terrifying so
it was certain parts of new york city
were scary yes we're very scary
uh where i love was fine it was not a
big deal uh i would say that
living through the pandemic what did it
teach me what did i
walk away with um go hard
yeah come if you're coming back yeah
bring up gather all the self-esteem
leave your stupid clothes at home
and just bring all that in and go as
hard as possible yeah i lived through it
here i'm fine
right and i was cautious right and the
subways are not so bad now
yeah and i think because people are uh i
think because there's more people out
which means that more money is trickling
down to the homeless
yes and the crazies and that is better
for the city yes because the thing is
before there weren't enough people on
the subway
these homeless people are now starving
right and nobody's looking
and the few like it subway cars if you
had like one or two people filled in it
right
right no one's gonna give you money
percentages drop dramatically
but when you got like a decently filled
subway car you get a couple dollars
and that's okay so now that the city's
bouncing back
i think homeless people and people that
are on the streets are pro
are less aggressive i i i
it's so funny to to say this because i
i grew up here yeah i grew up on long
island
i lived here for years
and when i come back here i love it i
love being here i don't feel like
i don't feel like it's home i've gone
i've gone too far off the reservation
yeah no this isn't a home to you
yeah look at where we're at yeah yeah
yeah
i'm like i'm like gone from here i'm
softer now yeah like i'm not as hard
like you know the whole new york heart
like [ __ ] it right i don't give a [ __ ]
somebody's bleeding on the subway i
think that's cool i think it's cool when
kids get shot
it's gritty [ __ ] yeah yeah new york do
it dot
i'm just not like none of that makes any
sense to me anymore
you know as i get older i start going
it's nonsensical
you know what i i realized my thing is i
don't want to be new york tough
yeah i want to be i want to be midwest
considerate
those people treat each other relatively
well yeah
i remember being in chicago the first
time and that's not even chicago
they don't people from the midwest don't
even consider that right a real taste of
the midwest
right some woman i was talking to uh
a buddy and i was like i gotta find a
chase atm
and some woman pops up out of nowhere
well if you go who are you yeah
i almost flipped out on you yeah and i
go this is not a right way to act
yeah you know what i mean the city does
something to you yeah
and and i think that's good yes and i
think the great innovations and the
great
you know things that we've learned to
appreciate
whether it's in the realm of art or
wherever right uh
come from being shaken out of your
comfort zone yes
and being willing to shake yourself out
of your comfort zone
right but i do think there is also some
value
to not losing yourself in this city no
no and and i know a lot of people who i
love and who
whom i have great respect for who i feel
like you know
when new yorkers i used to think new
yorkers were the worldliest people in
the world
no and now like when like new yorkers
leave new york and they're like
i remember going to new orleans with
giannis and sam marill and they were
like
why can't you get a slice why can't you
get a turkey sandwich
i'm going guys there's a food here right
that doesn't exist anywhere else
yes creole food doesn't really exist
anywhere else in america right it's this
amazing
fusion of like french caribbean haitian
all this stuff
and it's only here why are we talking
about turkey sandwiches
but they never stop it's a common new
york thing to walk into a place that's
not new york city and then immediately
compare it to something that's new york
city
and then to be a complete piece of [ __ ]
about it yeah it's like oh wait wait
creole john
you mean this is like halal guys yeah
right right right
yeah it's like it's like a french halal
guy
it's like no it's not it's it's not and
some i used to do that all the time ben
met me yeah you did
all that and i still do it yes i still
do i still find myself doing it but i
catch myself yeah like or like uh cafe
du monde
yes you take new yorkers there and
they'll be like
zeppolis right right what no no no this
is like bagels thrown in a deep fryer
it's like that's not yeah that's not
that i just appreciate something that's
not
yeah and i i've just gotten to the point
now where i i love it i come back here i
feel like
i'm on a vacation yes and i've
surrendered to los angeles for good or
ill
you have surrendered you called me
surrendered and uh
first of all i saw like a 3-1 own number
i don't know if i can give that it's
zip codes it's fine yeah and i don't
find it yeah
it's and i just i got two numbers from
that and i was like
some someone really wants to spam me on
some [ __ ] yeah someone wants to tell
me my
my uh my warranty's overdue yeah and
then it was you and i was like oh [ __ ]
but i do want to also tell you that you
have been selected by marion
i mean it's funny that you mentioned
that because you have been selected as
well
i thought i when you were like i'm
staying here i sent you the wrong hotel
yeah yeah when you send me i was like
i just um i don't know i when i went out
there
i was i think i didn't know if i was
done
you found your place there yes you were
doing well here
yes you were everything was going was
clicking in place
for you the shows were uh what's it
called you got uh
there was like things that you were
getting yeah montreal whatever the
comics to watch
and uh and it but i still felt like
there was something missing
yeah and then when you went out there
it's just like it's like you figured
that out
well i figured it out i hope and i
figured it out with this kid's help
right and we see it out in a garage
i'm gonna have to kidnap him on the way
out he should he's amazing yeah we
figured it out in the garage
i hope you're ready to start over yeah
by the way he always is
yeah okay there were others before me
right they just weren't funny
yeah some of them look like me he's got
a little bit of a chubby irish fetish
anyway not knock it in coving took most
of them out
covert took most of them yeah no it's
shockingly nobody
who deserved to dive covered right yeah
um
but there was some there's real
there's real moments of like [ __ ] you
know and as i get older now i think just
more about like
yeah we all gotta plant the flag
eventually
yeah and try to find or create some type
of home
yeah and i think i have to do it in los
angeles right
you know right it's not austin it's not
austin texas
no i tried yeah four months right gave
it a shot
i knew i this is the thing i i was uh
after my set i had to leave i had to do
i had to do a show and
you know yeah yeah a specialty cheese
shop and a milk bar
right so i'm right as i'm walking out
you're talking about
uh how austin's got like things that
austin has that new york doesn't
right and i go as soon as i heard you
phrase it that way yeah i go he's done
with austin oh yeah yeah yeah
cause you're only throwing it in new
yorkers faces yeah because it's
enjoyable yes because it's fun
yeah it's just fun it's fun to tell new
york they suck yeah
and everyone knows i hate austin yeah
and the thing about austin is it's
it's it's a it's a it's a sealist town
and that's really what it is right
across the board it's not about
anything specifically across the board
it is not where the best and the
brightest go no it is it is where the
dullest
yeah yeah go yeah as historically as the
best of the dullest
you're the best of the dulles and i just
got to go and i love joe and you know
i'll work his club
you know when it opens or whatever i'm
i'm just
i i think it's a horrible place and i
wish nothing but pain for everyone there
i mean truly and i've been kind of
honest about that right
but you know but i've realized during
this pandemic that like life is short
yes life is short right and you ca and
bull you can't
i was you know a lot of your life you
spend bullshitting
yes yourself right and others and you
have to
because a lot of your life is like you
know
you're fighting with your own insecurity
you're fighting with your own sense of
like
self-worth right and you gotta like you
gotta build yourself
up and then you get then you knock
yourself down yeah and
and you try to get to this like stasis
where you're just like okay
i'm great i'm not a king and i'm not the
worst person that's ever lived
and that's hard for comics yeah because
every day we're like
it's tough ever you wake up and it's a
different it's a different feeling
yes or you do a set and it's a different
feeling you you leave and you're like
i'm the king of the world i'll walk that
tonight tonight was a fine show
i did great but it was not as well as
i'd done in the past
so i'm like you know i was just unhappy
right
and uh my my sense of happiness is
you're very tied into how this goes
and that's not right but it's not i'm
too old for that yeah you know what i
started to realize
i'm actually too old
yeah for it no as somebody older you are
right
it's too it's too much like i don't it
doesn't matter how the sets go you just
walk away and it's just like who gives a
[ __ ]
yeah yeah somebody i was telling my
girlfriend i'm doing your podcast she's
like oh this is a big deal and i go
yeah i know it's it's good but you know
who gives a [ __ ]
i agree right like it's i'm happy to do
it
ship station if you have an online
business and you need to right now
the last thing you want to be worrying
about is shipping
okay the logistics of it that's why
shipstation manages everything it
provides you an infrastructure
to streamline all of your shipping
activities you can import orders
from any sales channel shipped with any
carrier using ship stations deeply
discounted rates and automate just any
shipping cash no wonder 100 000 plus
online sellers
choose sip station we use it and we love
it no matter how you sell
shopify etsy your own website ship
station funnels all your orders into one
simple interface you can manage from
anywhere even your cell phone
you'll even get access to amazing
discounts with major carriers including
ups fedex usps easily compare characters
and choose the best solution every time
with shipstation small business
can now access the same rates usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies
without the contracts or commitments i
say this
go to shipstation.com use my offer code
tim dillon
get a 60 day free trial that's two
months free no hassle stress free
shipping
if you are trying to get your company to
increase profitability
or if you're starting a new company
wouldn't it be nice to have two months
free
shipstation.com enter offer code
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
after spending late summer on the
sidelines we're really ready to get back
out there and make this year's lounge
season an epic one so bespoke post is
here to take your sun sand and surf game
to the next level with the lineup of
must-have box of awesome collections i
like these things
because what they are is you get a box
and it's full of really cool stuff
it's like 45 dollars it's like a 75 80
dollar value of the things that you get
there was this really cool box somebody
got me and it's grooming it's got a
detox scrub bar
it's got a knife uh a case for the
little sheath for it too sheath for the
knife i like
knives do you like knives
i do actually i like pocket knives
i have a k-bar i have a it's the one
that marines use
bespoke post is great because you can
get
cool stuff that surprises you
in a box every month
yes yes and what's exciting about that
is you can curate the box but you'll
never know exactly what's in it
right so you can basically take a quiz
they know your interest they know what
you're about
but they send you stuff that's very fun
they have some cool breezy summer styles
they have some cool prints on
some shirts what about the knife well if
that's your thing
by all means do that i don't really want
a summer style
i want a knife
i want a sharp knife so you want the
outdoor gear i'm more of like i think
the grooming goods would be cool i don't
care about the outdoor gear
i want it nice
every month i want another knife
i even i'll even tell bespoke post don't
don't waste your time don't waste your
time
giving me a bottle opener or a pair of
gloves
i don't need any grooming i don't need
any of that just
every month send me
a box with a knife in it or more than
one knife
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code tim
miller on the checkout
that's box of awesome dot com code
typical for 20 off your first box
i love it you love it we all love it box
of awesome.com
code tim dillon for 20 off your first
box
well i'm happy to talk to you we haven't
spoken a long time i think
what makes podcast good
is that you i have genuine interest in
what you have to say
right and there's i don't have a lot of
guests on the show because i don't have
genuine interest in what a lot of people
have to say
right um but you know you were the
first friend i had in comedy yes truly
yeah and and you're not white i want to
say that because i always get accused of
like racist
i'm like everybody's you know am i am i
am i like tony woods to your dave
chappelle
you are you are here i'm going to be on
they ready to next counter and
narratives
you're countering a narrative no but and
and you were the first dude who
loved comedy yeah that i really became
friends with
who loved comedy and we
we had a lot of other friends we knew a
lot of other people right and their
relationship is comedy is what it is
but the you know but you were the first
person where i was like
this guy loves coming he cares about it
yes
you cared so much about it right and you
wanted it
to be you you i remember we would be at
your house
and your mom would make us dinner yeah
and really good dinner oh my god butter
chicken these really good indian dishes
she's
she's retired but i want to i want to
like chain her to a kitchen i know
you got to get her back i want to open a
restaurant and then open up those closed
burger shacks and have her do
do her own thing it was so good yeah and
i remember we would talk and that's back
in the era when like
we were just coming into the city as
like these long island guys yeah they
would always be
yeah they'd always like look down on you
of course yeah for good reason of course
yeah it's fair yeah it didn't help that
we ran in and be like you know eddie
murphy
yeah it didn't help we're basically like
eddie murphy right
right perfect i mean i'd call myself
eddie murphy you call herself kevin
james
[Laughter]
so just it didn't work but
no that was the era when we were
starting shows yes
wanted to be taken seriously right and
this was the era we were in our mid-20s
and we were like we are choosing this is
our life now
yes and that was uh and i'm so far away
from that now
right like it's so weird yes and i've
moved three steps from that
you as well like you're you're older you
have a girlfriend you're mature you've
lived this life
i mean how awful would it be yeah
if you come back here and i'm still like
gotta get a 12 o'clock midnight micah
yeah yeah that would be crazy
i would hope you'd come here to kill me
that would be crazy yeah it'd
strangle me with this mic cord if i
didn't find some semblance
yes you you love this is what you look
like comedy something
i've never loved anything else i know uh
that wasn't like other
girlfriends other than yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the dog yeah sure right but i
mean as a
as like a thing right i never loved a
thing
i didn't know you could do this as a
thing right i would
you know i would the first time i
watched uh i remember watching snl yes
and it was uh recently yeah no no no no
no like
this was and who was on uh kevin nealon
was doing the weekend update but i was
comedy to me
at like being indian and like me we
didn't see any of this [ __ ] right
i thought kevin nealon was legitimately
trying to get fired from his news job
yeah
i'm like this guy is gonna get fired
yeah he's making fun of the news
yeah and then i realized oh this is a
comedy show oh yeah
you can do this yeah and then i'd see
people on
tv telling jokes so you can actually do
this
and watching that and still being no
this is not even possible
yeah and then then getting able to do it
right and then for me that goes i would
never want to stop this
right any which way now what why do you
think there are
less immigrant uh
you know like the immigrant story
doesn't usually involve comedy yeah
because
uh and of course not because i mean
imagine
right if everyone's parents and
grandparents got here and said i want to
be a clown
if i mean they would turn the ships back
right yeah no absolutely they would
drive the ship into the statue
i remember like white people are so kind
of out of it and they don't really care
about their children
right that when we all said we're gonna
be comedians our parents are like hey
great as long as it doesn't involve us
yeah like my dad's like you're old
enough i don't have to drive you to the
comedy right
the reason why uh immigrants uh they're
worried when their kids do yeah it's
because the either the reason
why it happens or doesn't happen is
because your parents either beat you
hard enough
right to talk you out of it yeah or
didn't beat you enough
right and then you end up doing it right
and then quitting and then going i'm
gonna do a real thing
right and i i get it yeah [ __ ] i get it
my brother's a doctor
right first one in my family yeah is it
harder because to me
i think it's is it
is it at a certain point you stop
explaining right
and you can just you go people don't
have to understand your life decisions
yeah that to me is the big thing
right that if there's one thing that i
think the generation
under us it's it's not the pc or the
whatever and all the fighting and the
i don't even get on them but yes they're
a little ridiculous about that but the
main thing
maybe this ties into that or not i don't
know i would say
you don't have to win everyone
no that's no i see people out there
right whether it's their family their
friends their community yes
they need everyone that they've ever met
right to agree with them or to love them
that is a real recipe as a non-binary
bipoxist gender i don't
throw all the adjectives in front of
myself you don't need to win and you
don't just need to win enough people
yes just not you don't need to win
everybody right and it's great that way
yes and it's okay there's always people
on my show that shouldn't be
absolutely always people in the audience
some of them women
who aren't
it's not for them right and that's okay
yeah go watch a bachelor recap and
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
it's like i just there's it's we are
i think i think that's one thing i've
learned as i get older
is that i don't care
who likes gay people i don't care who
likes me
yeah i don't care who thinks i'm funny
outside of the people who already think
i'm [ __ ] like i want you to think i'm
funny
i'm going to work my ass off to
hopefully have you think that
i want you to think i'm a decent person
right i don't need you to think i'm a
great person
i'd like you to think i'm smart i don't
need you to think i'm i don't want you
to think i'm a genius
i don't think i'm a genius but i've also
learned to take the foot off the gas
with that stuff
because i think that's the stuff when
you first started that was a big deal to
you
huge it was a big deal huge yeah you
wanted people to know
yes everything and like you this is my
journey this is my ride
and this is the thing some people that's
not their bus
right yeah they're not they don't give a
[ __ ] absolutely they just want
they want the yucks yes give them yucks
yes that's it yeah now when i first
started i i thought
um that we all
our job was to
inflict ourselves on people
to a point where they
just said okay yeah all right
right and and and part of that i
i've now learned that that is a colossal
waste of time
yeah you know personally and
professionally yeah
you know what made me realize that was
when i uh i was on the subway
yeah and i saw some guy like singing
but it was awful yeah off-key terrible
some people enjoyed it right and i'm
right
and i'm like i guess that's for you yes
and there were a bunch of other people
who were like get this guy off the
[ __ ] train
throw him under the train right that's
how some some guy felt like he put on
his headphones he's like and he was
ready to fight the guy
right and i was just like so that's what
it is yeah
and that's okay yeah who you get you get
and then you move on
i think that's the way the way that one
thing that i think
younger people don't seem to have a
grasp of yet
yeah is that you can waste a lot of time
trying to win
yeah i can't find uh like my audience is
not gonna be
indian people right i mean you know this
right i can't do
my audience is not gay people yeah right
yeah like i've done i'll get hired for
indian gigs right
i talk them out of it right i'm like you
know what's a great idea
talking to each other yeah how about
that how about
saving money why do you think it is that
you have a similar relationship with
indians that i have with gays
in terms of our comedy
we're like we're not the star of our
community
no not that that's a good or bad thing
right why are we not the stars of our
community why did we don't
why are we not drenched in our community
i i think because we were meant to look
at it differently right
and that's the only thing i can come up
with yeah you just gotta it's you're
meant to see it from a different
perspective
right to give you an angle that hey
guess what not all indians are
uh doctors lawyers right they're guys
who sound like mechanics
yeah you know right so it's like you got
to deal with this
yeah or like if you're if you're gay
it's like this is not what you know
yeah it comes in so many other different
ways packages right
it's it's strange and you'd think that
the the people whose job it is
to make sure that things are
interesting out there in entertainment
we value that
yeah they don't they want to fill the
protocol
yeah they wanna it's like okay cool like
we'll have
we'll hire the indian guy because it
looks good right but to me the bigger
deal is
when you have the indian guy in
central pennsylvania yeah that's a
bigger deal to me
yes you put uh the gay guy in long
island to headline the clubs
right because he guess what yeah he gets
the work done
right that to me is a major that's
important that's that shifts the needle
right not the place not the channel that
goes we have an
obligation to hire somebody who is
who's indian or gay whatever right it's
to me it's the place
that's deep seated than elk's lodge yeah
who goes
you know what let's get this indian guy
in here yeah and
not because it's the good thing to do
because we love this guy because he's
funny he's funny
because he's gonna entertain the [ __ ]
out of us that's right yeah that's
that's what i think was more important
because that's what that's at the bottom
like the bottom line at the end of the
day that's our entire life
and that's what shifts everything right
to be honest that's what changes
people's perspective
yes you know many times there's people
they'll come up to me like
you know i didn't i didn't think a hindi
comic could be this funny
right and i go i know that they use
hindi comics yeah
and i'm i'm like i don't even know how
to respond to that right
buy the album though right
i take venmo yeah yeah venmo me
yeah so what do you think is the uh
do you ever see yourself outside of the
city
that's that's another thing that i've
been wrestling with is like can i live
elsewhere i see somebody like you know
you go to like los angeles i've seen
another a bunch of the new york comics
go to l.a
yeah and some uh you know you had heat
going out
yeah and a lot of them didn't yeah but
they still seem pretty happy out there
it's an adjustment yeah they seem and i
didn't think it's possible
right because i have that same mentality
where i go well what if i need to get
right what if i what if i need yeah uh a
slim gym
at 2 30 in the morning yeah where will i
find it yeah how about
have a not have one yeah how about it's
okay
it's weird because
so much of our lives are this shitty
career
and even though it's a good career and
i've done you know great things in it
and you haven't we've all
enjoyed it and this is why we exist
right right yeah
it's still shitty yeah cbs bull yeah
i've done good things
you have yeah yeah now have you seen me
on little voices on apple plus
yeah yeah well i don't have apple plus
no i will watch
listen if you just use the free trial
membership well i think i think
kathy griffin who i'm sure doesn't love
me if she knows who i am but i will
quote her and say
the only award in comedy is to say
you're still doing it yes
that's it right the only award that a
comedian will ever get
is to say they're still doing it right
yeah i remember used to quote joan
rivers it's about who can stand in the
rain the longest
yeah yeah that's probably true
yes um and the problem is i think a lot
of people now aren't they're standing
but it's not in the rain
they think they're in the rain no yeah
they're like looking it's like a gray
day and they're like this
seems like rain right yeah i don't know
i got a i remember a facebook memory
popped up and i saw an old show flyer
wow from seven years ago yeah and i just
go
and i'm looking at some of these people
a lot of them quit they all quit
yeah everyone quit riders now some of
them are writers some of them are wrong
so they're not going to do this
yeah they're not going to get on stage
like why would i
right i collect 1500 a week yeah we're
not going to
show up right and and you know that was
never the life
for you or me no it was not too much
too much felt like a day job yeah i
can't do that yeah i once i had a gig
where i had to
go there once a month to help write
bits really for the radio and and what
happened and
every and it'd be like okay cool it's
150 bucks
right and but i would dread the entire
time
the day before i go i gotta get up i
gotta go in there
i gotta talk to people yeah i gotta sit
here and be like
this is a good jingle right no no yeah
throw me off the building yeah i can't
do this nonsense we got to do it the way
like on our own terms yeah yeah yeah
that's the thing that
that i figured out how to do i think
that's the biggest thing that i figured
out how to do
was that i didn't need the people that i
thought i needed
no that's the real [ __ ] yeah man you
figured that [ __ ] out
yeah real well yeah yeah and i think
it's part of it
is like you depending on the type of
person you
are right like like coming out of the
closet i think is part of it because
years and years ago
when i came out of the closet i'm like
well maybe my friends won't like me
anymore
but who cares no doesn't you know what i
mean and i think
every decision i've made in my life has
kind of been a little similar where i go
yeah i might lose people by moving l.a
people might not think i'm a serious
comic or they might not like or maybe if
i do this video and i put a wig on
people are gonna think i'm an idiot
right and they're gonna be like that's
not the right way to do it
you should be the comedy seller you
should be here you should be there
and maybe if i do logan paul's podcast
people might think i'm a sellout or
a piece of [ __ ] or whatever um and every
time i have one of those
decisions i go yeah but [ __ ] them right
that's really the reality yeah but [ __ ]
them
okay you know and i think that
that's the thing that i would probably
say
has been the the best guiding thing i'm
going to leave here and steal a car
i mean there's plenty of stuff in the
hotel district
i mean i've taken a few things already
about
after you don't have to steal anything
from outside you can steal stuff from
inside
i'm stealing your producer that's the
first thing that he's got yeah he's
great
he is good he's a little bit entitled
yeah
i can tell he's but i've made him a
monster right
no i've made him a monster yeah i mean
like
i forget what he did the other day but
he goes
like he'll be eating a restaurant eating
lobster bisque he'll go yeah
spoon he walked up to me expecting me to
with wet hands expecting me to dry them
oh yeah yeah that's real real piece of
[ __ ] that's the type of behavior yeah
you've really created something yeah
i've created a monster it's disgusting
you shook wet hands at me yeah he really
just is he's really leaning in
to that part of his personality uh when
i met the guy
he was working at a pet
[Laughter]
all store urban pet urban pet urban pack
not even a chain
is it a chain it's a chain but in l.a oh
yeah they're
even worse it's your your pet's an urban
pet why what they're not
it's not a country pet it's an urban
path it's just a collect of those
hairless cats
yeah that's all they sell it's just
mexican hairless cats
it's like it's it's for like it's for
like we want your dog to feel like he's
on a farm
right so it's all that type of horseshit
and i met him there
and he was brushing a dog's teeth yeah i
still think it would be a good idea for
him to like
work there for two weeks a year just
that's his vacation
to kind of get it back you should make
his vacation where he gets a regular job
yeah i agree with i think that that's
fair i think it's not the worst idea
yeah because his day-to-day life
is a vacation yes and then you know how
like well he doesn't see it that way he
thinks he's hell hell
right to his wife all the times on the
phone the wife oh you know we were at
the hamptons i had to eat the lobster
again
it's a horror to him right i had to sit
there while he talked to someone
and yeah he's a demon right this guy's
talking to one of the biggest investment
bankers of the world i just sit here and
listen to this yeah he's got some other
journalists on and they're talking about
whatever
sure i'm going to use it for insider
trading but how exhausted
how exhausted
you know i've taken this kid all over
the world the bitcoin conference right
and he's got the yeah so his vacation
quote unquote yeah
should be send him to a petco this is
the thing that new york doesn't have you
don't have producers
everybody wants to be the guy right
everybody wants to be the guy
i still look at podcasting like it's uh
collecting uh
action figures right i'm like i'm
leaving here going
so podcasting might work
i'm sitting in a goddamn hotel with a
living room
yeah it's nice and i'm going podcasting
might be the thing
yeah yeah no idea yeah it's good
do i get a hyundai elantra for doing
this we
actually we actually charge you to do
this
that's how people keep money damn
we're actually gonna venmo our request
you know jesus if you don't mind
and we're going to but if the money
doesn't go to us it goes to dax shepard
spotify doesn't have the money so we got
to kick up right to spotify so they
could pay
dax
why don't you get high oh you're upset
get high and lay in a pool of money i
don't know call a hooker
there's not that many things in life
that make you happy no humming
eating a hug right i don't know how many
of those you can buy but
two out of the three yeah it's not this
is gonna be an interesting podcast to
listen to of his
do you talk to anybody
who was your boy you had like a best
friend
uh like in real life was his name trevor
no yes yes well trevor wasn't my best
friend he was a good friend
he was a good friend yeah but there was
another kid that was well like from
from like home yeah this guy chris
yes yes yeah what happened to him he
man he lives in italy
no yeah he's got a baby got a wife
how did that happen he was backpacking
through italy lost his job
backpacking through italy and he met uh
he was on the train and he met this girl
and he just started talking to her
started seeing her and then
went to school in milan yeah and now he
lives there and he's got a baby
lovely kid kids growing up and it's just
so
crazy because like you look at a life
like that
yeah and you go oh my god it's out there
people do it that's [ __ ]
mind-blowing yeah and uh you know that's
well the guy trevor he's dead but that's
not that's not what happened to him
i think he overdosed on pills but that's
not the point let's go to italy again
yeah let's go
back to milan back to italy yeah i mean
like that's a great way you you just
said something that's great
people do it yeah there's actually
people that do it
yes right that's crazy they find that
happiness
like i look at his life and i go that is
beautiful
dad is really beautiful yeah so but
maybe
maybe he's in italy and he's going i
wish i had a podcast
maybe you think maybe he's thinking
maybe man it would be
it'd be great to drive canal's mom's hrv
yeah
i think he might go this woman and this
child
have kept me yeah from what i really
want to do
right you just talk to joe rogan about
bigfoot
[Laughter]
that's what i want to do i mean if he
thinks that
yeah that's got to be the saddest thing
in the world well we all have our
disease
yeah i guarantee it's not this but
no there's something that gets every
there's something that gnaws it
ever all of us you think so i think so
you think so i think of the quiet
moments
in the darkness and i think it gnaws at
us because there's
there's something crazy about this life
we know it ends
yeah which makes us just different than
ever like
most animals i'm sure elephants you know
higher conscious
you know but most animals you see them
they're like going around going like
yeah this is
hey man this is all good right now one
day it's just it's over
uh we know the sense and we know that we
have to make all of these
choices we know it's a game where there
are choices
and we know that each one of those
choices
there's then results in um
a few things that we expected to happen
and a few unexpected things
and i think that the more of those you
make
there's always a part of you
just by the design of this whole entire
thing whatever this is a high level
video game being played by aliens who
the [ __ ] knows
you say to yourself it's so natural to
go
what if i had made a different choice
even when the choice you made was great
even when the things that came from the
choice
are good i still think
because it's the insanity right it's
crazy yeah
that thought pops in your head you knock
it out yeah i think that that to me
uh when you start to do that that to me
feels like i'm uh
flirting with a bad place oh yeah
yeah i don't i don't do that that to me
feels like i'm flirting with depression
i don't want to i don't it's a bad place
yeah i go past it now
yeah there's no more hanging out there
anymore smart yeah i just go you know
what it happened
it is was was it is what it is and then
i move
forward past that because you could get
stuck in that [ __ ]
and then you're going you know what you
ever have what's the thought recently
that you had with that
um even like if i should have devoted
more of my life
to my uh mental and physical well-being
and less to this
industry right yeah that's you know
yeah i mean that's sure that's part of
it sure
only because i've met some of the most
successful people in this business
many of them are criminally insane yeah
i mean they could fill
swimming pools with money and do
backstroke in it but at the end of the
day
um it's it's your shadow boxing ghosts
here
uh you know
it's not you know what is that it's the
speech from the wire
okay the job won't save you not it's
like
so i think to myself sometimes
what is what is this at the expense of
what is this what is this
this this cool [ __ ] that i'm able to do
which i love doing
right what is
the cost that's what i think of
right sometimes there's always a cost
i think if you
send uh i think you can eliminate that
feeling
yeah that mental feeling with heroin
[Laughter]
no no no no no it just it's just gonna
take you just gotta
sit back and uh
send um ben to a pet shop yes
i think he does and that'll sort like
how good would that feel for you to
watch him there oh no i i
i'm i'm planning on doing horrible
things
but i i think that's by the way i think
anyone that does
i think that's a pretty common thought
right for people
they go hey what what else could i be
doing
but if i wanted to do something else i
would yeah and that's the thing though
right
yes i've done podcasts right and i've
said to myself
okay let me try this right and
someone said to me he's like oh you
didn't stick with it yeah and i go
no right i didn't care for it right
let's just
accept that first yeah i it's like you
know people so those questions like
well why haven't you why didn't you keep
doing that
it's like well you know i during the
pandemic i created a game show
right okay and i shot a few episodes
created a whole game show played it with
comics it was fun
somebody was like why it's a really good
idea you should keep doing it
and i go i don't want to right you only
have a certain amount of time
right do the things you want to do do
the things you want to do
that's it right and then and you know
and then you
everything else will be fine because
it's absolutely
it's over then yeah man it's over that
quick
yeah and i just want to do more of the
things i want to do
and i think that's hopefully what we've
all learned right
you know that what we want to do
as long as it's not hurting anyone else
well that's debatable
and even if it is yeah who cares right
life is too short one of the funniest
moments was throwing rocks from a roof
you know what i mean yes
i laughed i never laughed so hard when
was that i was like a child
i'm not saying i'm gonna revisit it oh
right yeah yeah but it's just like
all right nobody got hurt but you know
what i mean sometimes jeffrey i've seen
joseline maxwell
hey questionable characters sure
right but they lived yeah they
truly lived that they truly lived yeah
i don't have an island no and i think
that's like
that that's what it comes down to it's
like what what makes us
truly feel alive because happiness is a
weird goal
but if you feel alive and you feel like
you're living
it'd be nice to not do it at someone
else's expense but there are
countless people that do there are
countless people that do yeah and i get
it and i understand the reasoning for it
but at the same time it's just like i
think that if you can live
make yourself as happy as possible
without at the expense of somebody else
that would be great right but just do
that man right
do that yeah get [ __ ] happy get
[ __ ] happy tell people again what is
your album
out there oh you're a great stand up
thank you it's hard to get people
to to to figure out
uh because people just don't trust
anything anymore and
right you know that it's hard for people
to find stand up
yeah it's uh the album is called draw
four
draw four yeah it's uh you know based on
the uno card yeah
and uh you know it's my current draw so
it's
i love that yeah little r4 uh yeah you
can find that everywhere
canal aurora draw four album
find him on social media um
alldaykca.com yeah that's it yeah
that's his website check up on him
send him a nice positive message maybe a
negative one i'm definitely
i'm gonna get a couple negative ones i'm
i get a couple
i'm getting negative ones sitting here
about whatever i mean yeah of course
screaming at me
today because i said i'm like hey i'm
vaccinated which they know already
right and i'm like hey guys i don't care
what you do yeah
my literal stance was i don't care if
you want to get it great
right i want to get it fine i'm 36 i got
it
yeah i i needed to show my vaccine thing
to perform at the comedy store like
and i imagine it'd be i'll i'm gonna
need it to travel i don't know if i will
maybe i won't
right but i'm like i don't care what you
do that's not enough for people
no you can't it's by the way my opinion
is a non-opinion
it's a non-opinion
that's what sets people off because they
want to be
told what to do or validated because
then they're back in this good verse
evil thing
of winners and losers and right and
wrong and yeah i'm on this side now on
that side and it gives their meaningless
lives meaning
meaningless lives meaningless
and it's not my fault they're
meaningless but they're meaningless
because you're mad
at me on twitter for the simple opinion
that i don't care what you do
i don't think there's a right answer and
a wrong answer
in every instance for everything and
people got angry at that totally
unrelated this episode is brought to you
by pfizer
yes it has nothing to do with anything
yeah
bill and melinda gates have been so kind
to me
and this show yeah one guy goes i'm
fanning myself with the check by the way
from pfizer one guy literally
said to me goes you're being paid by
pfizer i'm like
pfizer does not sit around and go what
guy can we get in here who's questioning
to also pop our vaccine all right and
i'm not pumping i'm like it's like
hey man if you're fat if you've done bad
things to the body
yeah this might you know if if you're 20
and you don't want to do it you're like
[ __ ] it hey god bless you
right or if you're older you know people
are not doing it
some of them some people are doing it
and getting [ __ ] up from it not good
some people are not doing it and dying
from covered yeah i mean not good i hope
it sounds terrible
it sounds not fun and there's people
dying it's just got to be embarrassing
right and and listen i get if you
there's a lot of people that like
playing the game and mm-hmm
whatever but but my non-opinion which it
is it's not in a
it's it's like i don't care i truly
don't care right of course it doesn't
matter i'm
you know you question why you care
on either side why it's such a big deal
for you if you get vaccinated
you're vaccinated if your neighbor
doesn't they're not
mm-hmm you can live together you can
live in a happy world
use promo code tim j dillinger modern
yeah yeah by the way pfizer
dot spicer
[Laughter]
for the booster you know you're gonna
love that booster
you're gonna need it when the delta
variant comes the delta the lambda baby
you're getting it all
i'm telling you right now it's every
year it's going to be a new booster show
oh it'll be a new booth it's going to
it's pumpkin spice
it's going to be you got your hulu your
netflix
right your booster shop yeah that's it
that's your year monthly expenses
subscribe and find it's gonna stick you
and they're gonna go
subscribe and yes you might have belle's
palsy and yes
you might die sure everything tastes
like piss
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't all of
a sudden you're like i can't taste
anything right i've lost control of my
tongue
yeah yeah it's that everything feels
like the temperature of a wet but i'll
tell you whoever the ceo of pfizer is
he's going to be in a
really nice house yeah and someone's got
to be here i'm on luminary
yeah yeah the ceo pfizer has a new
podcast
with jack sheppard jack shepard's gonna
tell him why it's okay
even though a few people uh you know
can't chew anymore
and he's sad about that dax shepherd's
gonna he's the armchair expert yeah he's
gonna tell you he's gonna tell the ceo
of fires or why things are okay
it's fine if you're sneezing teeth yeah
casey aurora canal aurora
find him casey all day thank you so much
yeah thank you i appreciate it thank you
brother appreciate it